you were writing the mister before you
even started doing J's yes I wrote a
very rough draft at the mr. back in 2009
and it just wasn't right and it's taken
me this long to I've rewritten it three
times that's for you to get to this
point I'm so glad that I finally got it
out there because these two characters
have been shouting at me for a long time
what is it like to step away from a
project to do something else completely
and for a lot of time and see it through
like so many stages and then finally
come back it's just it's a relief to get
them out of my head and yeah I think
that's that's the main thing I just
wanted to tell their story and I'm
really glad that it's finally out there
yeah so what is their story what is the
mystery I think that I think
fundamentally it's I like sort of
opposites attract kind of kind of kind
of stories and this is it's about a very
rich young man who comes into a new gen
heritance and he falls in love with his
housekeeper
much to his surprise and their surprise
as well so so it's about that it's about
the the unit quality so much inequality
and it's growing day by day and this
planet and and you know I'm looking at
all of that from the other end of the
telescope now and it's it's there's an
element of that in there but it's
basically a very passionate love story
between your two young people that sort
of thing I like to write and passion is
like underlined three four five six
times like they get very very steam this
we like steamy yeah yeah do you get a
bit of a kick out of but the reaction
that people get like the provocation
like it's people look at it and go this
is this is steamy Avada they're like
well I I you know I there are loads
there are thousands and thousands of
we've been writing in this genre yeah so
it's you know if anyone who's writing in
it and reading in it it's it's it's
that's what don't used to it's just that
because 50 went so mainstream
for reasons that still mystify me then
then then I think there's so much
attention given given to us but there's
plenty of books out there with stimulus
yeah yeah so what is your what is your
process like you said you rewrote this
about three times I imagine it's like I
just gotta get it right are you yes are
you harden yourself when it comes to
Barry I think I think anyone is that
there is their own worst critic I mean
and I get my fair share of that I mean
more than my fair share only but it's
yeah I think I think it's it's you want
to make it an enjoyable experience for
the reader and you want to pull them in
and keep them there and hook them right
through to the last page and that's you
know it's a challenge and it's it's one
that I I enjoy you know trying to see
through so what do you say to yourself
like you say just now like you're your
own risk reading your voice in your head
that says ah not that what is how you it
goes it fluctuates you think oh my god
this is great and then you go come back
- oh no no it's just it's just one of
those journeys and then we all have them
and in everything that we do yeah and
you know it's just it's just overcoming
all of them yeah now you went to Albania
yes well that was one of the reasons
when I had to had to rewrite things
whether there's a hair in my way yes I
went to Albania I I am I just couldn't
get a handle on my heroine she's from
Albanian and it's because our bang has
been closed off since until the early
90s when communism fell it's very little
written about it there is one amazing
book called the accursed mountains by
Robert Carver fantastic yeah
anyway I had to go and get a sense of
what she was like and
and it was it was incredible it was an
amazing I didn't know what to expect
and there it's a very very warm people
very hospitable and it was a treat to
actually get to her town and see it in
amongst the mountains and what have you
but having spent some time there I've
got a bit more of a sense of what she's
like so that must have been a bit of did
you consider that an ambitious choice to
choose a character coming from a place
where you knew that you weren't going to
know about it maybe I just you know it I
just happen to randomly in 2009 think
I'll make it from Albania so is this
something that you would like to see
take on a life similar to what fifty
Shades havoc would you like this to go
on to your other media see that to a
movie we'll see yes what I'll say about
that yeah I mean there have been
discussions so we'll see where they're
kids I'm sure that anytime you put pen
to paper there's going to be interest
from now on right uh I don't know I mean
I suppose it depends on on what reaction
I get from from people who like to read
my stuff yeah you know so we'll see what
have you learned over the course of the
journey that you took with Fifty Shades
about turning something into a film
about presenting it in another medium
that you if you do it again or will do
it again let's say necessarily this book
that you might do differently like what
have you learned I would make sure that
whoever is working on borders is
passionate about the material and and
wants to keep it in the spirit of how
the book is and wants to keep it within
within that that's but for the fans of
the books yeah that's that's what I have
learned so I think 50 shares was a bit
of an eye-opener for a lot of people
yeah maybe like it was first interaction
with that type of romance novel that
sort of Stannis how does it how does the
mr. compare to that
well it's interesting because the the I
never considered that Fifty Shades to be
a BDSM book but it that's sort of the
background to it
and and you know that's Christian is
into that particular lifestyle in this
but this other book that the sex is sort
of very much character driven mhm so
it's a little bit more conventional but
there it's still there and you know
conventional sex could sexy too